社長ドローンキャラクターボイス肇社長そうなんで自体は有用なに女ねぇ
声優してますこちら初めて超ですプレス定方ば続く中皆さんご繁盛されてますでしょう
かお店に食べるのが強いときはお店で食べずねお店で買って帰ってきてお家で食べる
っていうのをよくしてるんですけど
やべえも見つけたんですよね色んなテイクアウトのご飯イロンってあるともですけど
もう風さんがお持ち帰りで飛んではなく野外メニュー準備しておりました
を買ってきますはぁ
ハズレ
えっ
ん
ムラーノ信じる発見特定の店舗でしかやってないみたいです
移動します
夏やここはあでらしい伝説のメニューが入ってきます
えっ
[音楽]
やっと動きましたはい買ってきましたらこちらでこれ一品しか2問してないからねあん
でを2つになってる
こちらでその盛り付けますね
a
これで一人分なんかな
多分一人分だよねやでも待ってはお店で買っただけお箸何でも付けしますかって言われ
た
全力から下5キロ千円を持ち帰るということでこちらに5キロの唐揚げございます
オーブ今年ご飯禁止なんで
こちらから込めて贈りたいんですけどもここはしっかりと体だけで1キロ4回食って
いきたいとおもいます
状態は上がってきましょうかもう君だったら姉属性2だけだしたいと思います義妹
メリー号いただきますただ1キロで升頂きます
もん
ちー体で一番幸せうーん
かつやのカラーでこんなをしてノレ食ったことなかったんですよまで
なんかもうハチャメチャに柔らかいですねお肉がすごい柔らかい
ポッ
[音楽]
1 k ってぱすごいね量がどうなんだろ本当はなく家族で一個買ってみんなで食べる
みたいなパターンが多かったんですけどこれからすると体カードで1品でうって言って
いる言葉の1人用なんてよ俺からすると
[音楽]
あああ
宇部食いてーこれからぜてご飯払う
弁当で拭いたかったでも俺には酒がある皆さん今何しが入ってますが奥ヒールのずに
ちゃんですよ
これず
軽いラガー
[音楽]
あの言おうか迷ってたんですけど
でかすみません金原上げてこんなもんだっけ
これが正しいのかうん
[音楽]
僕はちんこすこうです
まったく話変わるけど俺この後別の運動する撮影が待ってまして
俺ガッツリ抑えたんだけどこれ大丈夫か運動してまいっか
[音楽]
よやめてかじゃあ宮田ファラー h 黒すげーよ
普通の食べ物に地球たは4月よねもう afra の暴力
ある某
[音楽]
名古屋ばいらない細胞目的にお腹いっぱいなんですけどもまだ半分も食べてないですね
これ一ついてく奴じゃないなぁ
afra の量がなぜで一人でくんすごいところ一人でくれる人いたらちょっと本当に
頑張ってみますね
[音楽]
多いんだ
ますあの今回ねサー成功ならたハッチソースっておりさんこれぞとも頑張ります
[音楽]
やっぱ東風できて弾いてくだねこれこう挟めてきて責めなくなってきてめっちゃ硬いん
ですよ
ん
はめ以
[音楽]
うわぁ
らーんだぁーラスト1個いただきましたん
[音楽]
んんばー
もうなどが
[音楽]
うん
はい55分29秒47
[音楽]
20戸
bl
あのもうやばいまずてめっちゃクルーズがね美味しいですけどここはいえば冷たくなっ
て車か対し難関
最初がめっちゃ美味しかったですけどこれは絶対一人で言うようではないことが僕が
発揮で証明しました5人か6人で食べましょうおやすみなさい